in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Josh
and Mary are with us hey guys how are
you
hey Dave welcome welcome where you guys
from
Billings Montana Wow welcome all the way
to Nashville to do a debt-free the long
trip planes trains and automobiles
I understand how much have you guys paid
off $50,000 Wow how long did that take
you 32 months very good and your
household income range during that time
we started off about 53 up to 69
thousand
very good what do you guys do for a
living I'm a firefighter for the city
and I'm a nurse at a crisis pregnancy
center and stay home with the kiddos
good for you
very cool and how many kiddos have you
got two we have in it now - Gail I've
got three and then it's 15 months all
right very cool very cool cute kids
very nice all right fine so tell me your
story how did you pay off the fifty
thousand what started at thirty two
months ago
well it was more of a journey for us
Dave we we started out about seven years
ago
got married and we were just living on
love we had two cars that both had names
in about 20,000 dollars in student loans
and we just knocked that out as fast as
we could and said hey let's save for a
house and now just worked hard and we
saved about probably bout $50,000 and
then got an inherent inheritance of
about 90 and said hey that's a great
start for a down payment
put about 140 down on our house and
borrowed $50,000 and just then we kind
of really started your plan about about
that 32 months ago two months ago so
this is your house you got this yep I've
knocked it out Wow
so what's the house worth it's about one
195 probably wow that's a nice house and
buildings it is a lot of house that's
very cool congratulations man it's got
to feel great how old are you - I'm 34
and Mary's 31 yeah you paid for house oh
you day you're weird
and we've been blessed Dave you know I
mean we we know our blessings come from
and but we just really appreciate you
and your program because without it we
wouldn't be where we are today like I
said we got seven years later we have
two beautiful kids I paid for a house
about 80
thousand dollars in mutual funds and
it's just an uphill track and it's how
it's because you and your program well
you did it man he does her heroes way to
go
you're amazing I mean 34 years old you
paid for house oh my god this is awesome
whoo where did the inheritance came from
it was that part of it was from my great
aunt of mine um after she passed away
and then part of it was from a
great-uncle of Josh's okay all right and
both of them were savers so I mentioned
both of them aren't even smiling I think
you've got a paid-for house you didn't
go out and waste that money right no we
just you just invested it back into our
house and and just then just been
working hard ever since so we had people
ask us you know oh well what are you
gonna do is there you gonna invest it or
well but we were thinking about buying a
house in the near future well I think
we'll just put it towards our house and
mm-hmm some people were confused at that
yeah I don't know paid for and we got on
the plan and really just started budget
and that that 32 months ago and it in
the budget works that's what we want to
tell people is it really does when
you're on the same page of your spouse
and you're towards the common goal you
know we got that $50,000 and thought oh
it'll take us 10 years to pay it off
because it was a 10-year bank loan and
and then we've had projections for seven
and well 32 months we knocked it out
said we can do for a climber do this but
it works very cool so the budgets what
you blame it on and obviously you were
working together well any other tips for
people that want to have a paid-for
house by the time they're 34 I think you
know before starting a budget we were
both pretty frugal frugal we've always
been good at saving money but never
really had a plan and so that budget
really makes it to where it's like okay
we can do this if you map it out and for
me having a budget is is freedom because
I know what I have and I know where it
can go so before I have anxiety about
going in the store and buying a pair of
pants now I know because if I need a
pair of pants it's in the budget we can
do permission to spend right it really
is because you can do it without guilt
and still get your paid for ours
right yeah you got
No so how did you guys get connected to
our stuff I think my dad gave me a book
when I was probably 24 and you know it's
been 10 years ago and like I said I read
your stuff and knew a lot of it was was
really good stuff but we just didn't
really jump all in until I guess until
we had the mortgage and then we were
just we talked about that mortgage you
go okay I gotta get rid of it where's
that Dave Ramsey book I got you and you
get two little kids in your perspective
kind of change wake you up that's a good
way that's a better wake-up call than
that something more important than me
out there now so absolutely absolutely
well well done all right
Abigail and Emmett Josh and Mary from
Billings Montana $50,000 paid off in 32
months making 53 to 69 their 34 with a
paid-for
$200,000 house pretty stinkin incredible
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
awesome Oh which you were watching this
on YouTube it's the q-kidz
well done y'all well done that's
fabulous oh man if you didn't know we do
stream the show every day live for three
hours on YouTube you can watch the show
on our YouTube channel go to Dave Ramsey
show the Dave Ramsey show YouTube
channel and that's also where you can
subscribe if you'd like and you can get
all kinds of goodies there where we'll
send you out the debt free screams about
video and some of the rants and other
things we'll keep you up to date with
what's going on you can watch various
clips from the show in other words that
we post on our YouTube channel so lots
of fun stuff there people like the rants
they like the the stories the behind the
scenes stuff is very well done on our
YouTube channel so check it all out of
the Dave Ramsey show channel on YouTube
be sure and do that way to go guys
really really good debt free scream I'm
proud of you good job hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show and say you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind